kharkiv deuxième ville d'ukraine a été
pilonnée sans relâche entre fin février
et mi mai avant le retrait des forces
russes des bombardements et des
centaines de civils tués
nous avons enquêté pendant 14 jours sur
quarante et une frappe qui ont fait au
moins 62 morts
au moins 196 blessés dans les rues dans
les cimetières ou encore sur les aires
de jeux les témoignages des peignes des
crimes de guerre des frappes aveugles
les forces russes auraient utilisé des
armes à sous-munitions selon les ong
armes interdites par les traités
internationaux et même si la russie
n'est pas signataire celles ci sont
contraires au droit international
humanitaire dih skies il utilise des
armes qui sont très imprécises ce qui
signifie qu'elles ne permettaient pas de
faire la différence entre des cibles
militaires et des cibles civiles
le cas de kharkiv grande ville proche de
la frontière russe n'est pas isolé
depuis le début de l'invasion russe le
24 février dernier la justice
ukrainienne affirme avoir ouvert plus de
12000 enquête pour crimes de guerre dans
le pays